[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on fait une analyse
non verbale à 100% parce qu'on va
analyser les affiches de campagne des
douze candidats aux élections
présidentielles de 2022 donc là on est
sûr qu'il ya pas de mots il n'y a pas de
paroles n'y a pas de blabla on a imprimé
les douze affiches loïc qu'ils veulent
et mélanger pour un peu plus de
jeunes regardent pas chez tu le mélange
alors évidemment c'est cette analyse
sera sûrement relativement rapide l'idée
c'est de se dire puisque ces affiches là
rien n'est laissé à priori au hasard
qu'est-ce qu'on peut remarquer d'un peu
rigolo sur quel message ça envoie qui
cherche quoi on va voir ce qui est
possible de voir à l'intérieur de ça sur
les douze personnes de façon bien sûr
alors mon passé à normand passer ses
examens
mon présent du coup mon présent et mon
présent c'est qui c'est quoi c'est ces
gens
et mon futur du connu un essor à mon
futur le courage le courage le courage
et là bas c'est un bon tirage
malema langer je retourne la première et
on voit ce que ça donne on commence avec
valérie pécresse c'est ce qu'on peut
dire sur son affiche un lien avec moi
tient déjà à respecte les codes de la
droite c'est à dire le
les affiches tenues sobres un
trois-quarts on sourit pas vraiment mais
on n'est pas fermé le flou artistique
derrière mais on se demande si c'est pas
un faux floup on voit un peu une sorte
de détourage au touriste et ouais ben là
même sur verre les cheveux ça se voit
que c'est un peu des tours et oui mais
souvent la droite l'ancien droite enfin
il fait toujours partie de la droite
mais il a été souvent c'est flou un peu
vert et bleu derrière mélanger
moi je sais pas la chirac tous à la
sarkozy et tout donc je pense qu'après
ils sont a dit oh là là pour reprendre
les anciens codes pour rattraper les
anciens électeurs deux choses qui me
choquent pour une affiche de la droite
il ya du n'ya pas le mot france de danse
étaient les slogans de sarko chaka tout
mais toujours la france quelque chose ou
vers la france ou pouvant la france n'y
a pas et le deuxième truc mais qui je
crois se retrouvent sur pas mal la fiche
tu le vois où le logo de l air et oui
nos livres le parti est presque disent
ils parce qu'en gros on va dire elle
dans les élections d'avant c'était
vraiment la gauche et la droite qui
étaient les gros candidats tu sais latta
la droite et la gauche la gauche avec
hidalgo la droite avec pécresse regarde
le logo du ps il est tout petit ils ont
mis tout petit comme ça qu'ils disent
que c'est plus très bon et c'est
peut-être ça qu'a fait que les gens sont
plus à l'aise en ville dès tout petit
score toutes les deux tu as tous les
extrêmes droite et d'extrême gauche qui
qui ramassent quoi
oui alors ça c'est rigolo parce que
alors elle pour le coup c'est là on peut
voir la différence gauche droite dans le
message qui veut être envoyé ça on a
presque la même chose et pourtant il
n'ya rien qui paraît clair que tu as
quand même ce même flou comme ça qui est
derrière où elle est plus ouverte moins
formel puisque l apal avait ça allait
vraiment pour le coup souriante parce
que c'est un un vrai sourire c'est un
vrai sourire donc peut-être quelqu'un
lui a fait la blague de tir mon doigt je
peux seulement on peut on peut le voir
au niveau des pattes d'oie en fait si on
cache le bas du visage ça permet de voir
si c'est un vrai sourire ou pas et c'est
un vrai suaire se dégrader droz il est
très marqué par contre féminin bon je
pense pour essayer d'envoyer à le
pousser les les clichés positive de la
femme qui beaucoup de je suis c'est ça
qui peut je trouve qu'en jouant sur les
codes du rose et du féminin de ce qu'on
essaie d'éviter en ce moment on est
cliché pense qu'en rentrant dans les
clichés elle voulait jouer le truc à
l'écouté et c'est qu'il y ait plus de
gauche pour le coup alors qu'elle
essayait de jouer ce truc les trucs plus
strictes d'ailleurs elle utilise mots le
courage tu as le courage alors qu'ici on
a ensemble ouais je trouve que elle
symbolise bien quand même leur gauche et
la droite on n'est pas si surpris de ce
qui est utilisé par contre est surpris
de mon cash en cache les parties quoi
c'est à dire que là c'était vraiment la
campagne dont on n'est plus des partis
on est des entités quoi du coup on a
fait un idéal goût dans la foulée à jean
lassalle la france authentique ruralité
derrière très clairement sur le champ on
n'est pas sur les trucs où jusque là ses
limites urbain ce conte ce qu'on voit là
on mettre le film étaient tous là c'est
la campagne on est sur un truc qui est
répliquée droite tu vois regardant la
composition c'est à dire pareil centré
regard tourné en face alors que le corps
va vers la droite pour le coup et vers
l'avant les mélange de bleu et de vert
sauf qu'on a quand même un truc est plus
dans la ruralité les affirmé derrière
mon estomac on a presque des codes de
droiture pour les on pourrait les mettre
ensemble et ils sont très très formel
très attendu très peureuse date par
contre ça joue volontairement sur la
lumière du naturel t'as vu mais par
contre que celui là ils ont choisi alors
que nyon police plus et ça c'est plus
dans l'air du temps ouais et ça c'est
des trucs un peu plus alors je vais pas
le terme mais je crois que c'est sans
serif avec ses riffs à huy ouais c'est
des voitures ouais c'est plus dur et moi
actuelle et ça mettrait en avant les
majuscules ce qui était le cas il ya
encore quelques années ont joué beaucoup
sur sur les initiales des candidats
refusés ou des fois même table et leur
logo avec les deux initiales en gros et
c'est en fait c'est très ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux ont maintenant
on joue le nom et le prénom propre même
d'ailleurs les pseudos qui existait sur
youtube sont en train de changer pour
devenir des noms et des prénoms
quatrième tu continues et enfin fort
pour écouter et venez chez moi allez
j'en prends une eau à zahlé au hasard et
cela commence ouais alternance alors là
du coup on voit qu'on joue pas toujours
le flou bon vu comment c'est moi je peux
te dire quelque chose c'est que c'est un
photomontage oui donc ça joue un peu
comme jour là c'est le mot d'ordre
réalité mais là vraiment foule ou
réalité puisque tu vois un peu le cliché
du petit village français avec
effectivement l'église au milieu le
petit hameau dont le chant toujours et
après c'est mon skill un peu des centres
et comme ça on plus gros plan que les
trois autres passages ou encore sur lui
et surtout c'est un pompage de 1982 la
campagne de françois mitterrand avec le
clocher je ne sait plus d'où il était ce
clocher mais c'étaient les clochers de f
trouve que ça joue vraiment regarder moi
aussi j'ai mon clocher
moi aussi j'ai comme françois vous
l'avez élu pendant 14 ans en fait c'est
marrant qu'il essayait d'envoyer le
sourire avec le truc quand même très
très formel tout en voulant dire ouais
mais moi je moi je parle des vrais gens
en fait parce que la vraie vie la vanité
il en voit pas grand-chose de là pour le
coup quand tu vois jean lassalle qui qui
qui fait moins de chichi au niveau de la
ruralité derrière ils envoient plus un
truc de proximité que dupont union est
parce que les rappels tant papy tu aimes
bien où j'en sais rien tu vois mais là
il ya un truc qui sonne vraiment faux je
trouves tu mens
alors alors là on a de quoi dire yannick
jadot mon première chose je le vert
assumer le vert écologique là ya pas de
guerre civile deuxième chose ça peut
être la taille de sa tête quoi alors
dévolu aux logiques c'était plus gros
mais alors là c'est vraiment yard ont
fait en un petit un petit comparatif
comme ça juste car que le pain la tête
de jean lassalle c'est le nez de yannick
jadot l'un faire face avec un regard de
côté ses refasse surface bah ouais parce
que par rapport à un cerveau humain
quand un visage qui est aussi
prépondérant peux pas t'empêcher de
regarder ce visage peut pas trop
t'empêcher de lui faire face pour le
coup je trouve ça intéressant jeu
j'aimerais bien qu'on ait les avis de
ceux qui ont vraiment fait la
composition mais encore une fois lâche
pas c'est pareil tu vois europe ecologie
les verts séance est un tout petit plus
ils sont quand même là bas après ouais
non rien rien d'autre de trop précis à
dire quoi il ya eu que trois vrais choix
de fait qu'ils sont d'avoir mis ce
dégradé de vert pour représenter
l'écologie de se dire ok on met ça et on
le des centres là aussi pour le coup
quoi pour être obligé de faire face à ce
qui nous attend parce que ça nous a
envoyé 1 et de ports pour moi elle est
assez intelligente assez moderne
s'assied à alors en parlant de modernité
je sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé le nom
mais eux ils ont ils ont voulu trancher
ils ont voulu choquer mais bien c'est
marrant parce qu'on retrouve pas le
rouge du parti communiste mais c'est sa
mère regarde même le pcf le logo du pcf
et des idées de
toute ma vie j'ai jamais vu le parti
communiste communiqué comme ça tu vois
avec des couleurs qui se rapproche pour
le coup de la gauche tu vois on est on
est sur les roses et les piaules est
tous assez tôt des couleurs qui
appartiennent à la gauche avec en même
temps une composition de tenue c'est
qu'ils se rapprochent toujours de la
droite puis c'est cette baisse avec le
trois-quarts tourner sur la droite etc
ammann a pas de cravate parce que parce
que c'est le pc non mais jamais j'aurais
pensé que c'était le parti communiste
s'il ya une volonté de vous nous
racontez pas cette année on sera pas
invisible à vos yeux
c'est vrai que tu peux pas l'oublier
cette heure il faudra la au 2 août la de
pécresse et legault qui se ressemble un
petit peu ça la paf ça trop sort là il
existe là d'un fou quoi tu as la france
des joueurs heureux donc l'euro reprend
les codes bien dire la france la france
authentique la france des gens heureux
mais ça marche pas ça ne marche pas que
ce que tu vois la neige est d'accord il
a pas l'air très heureux bizarrement
dupont aignan a l'air plus heureux que
que russel merkel l'a la nuit
oui voilà la france des gens heureux
pour lui je vois et après par contre tu
fait choisir salle et sa liberté
qui sont trempés de candidats déjà
mélenchon alors que c'était le logo de
tf1 a déjà lui aussi est il là il a
changé d'habitude c'était à temps ce
serait pas un détourage là aussi
sèchement l'oeil pour y investir même si
beaucoup moins austère que d'habitude on
vient bien moins austère alors lui
clairement tournée vers la gauche tu
vois quand je te disais pour la gauche
et la droite tu voi l'orientation du
corps
après par temps de regarder de ce côté
là c'est regarder vers l'avenir tu
verras jamais quelqu'un regarder
les monstres c'est le gauche à droite
tout cas le sens des lectures des yeux
mais tu as pu mais même c'est plus du
tout le costume austère c'est beaucoup
de couleurs derrière c'est le bleu blanc
rouge qu'on retrouve un petit peu
partout l'union populaire là pour le
coup un petit monde ouais
donc on n'a pas eu la bonne affiche en a
eu la bonne photo mais pas la bonne
affiche bon on peut plus haut d'hier au
moins on est sûr que ces détours et
qu'ils ont changé les fonds là ils ont
même retouché changer le costume c'est
pas le même
c'est clair et c'est bien de photos
différentes ou par cuba si le même on a
ainsi si on avait même reflet là c'est
la même chose pour déjà lui mais le logo
de son parti beaucoup plus en avant on
prend la même place qu'un peu tout le
monde par contre est moins austère que
d'habitude là il est souriant qui
regarde vers l'avenir corps tourner
également vers la gauche et je trouve ça
envoie un truc très jeune et très
moderne d'essayer de mettre la cité
derrière à l'art de la cité au sens
global la city tu vois de deux là où les
gens habitent avec un truc très clair ce
sarcelles 2017 s'il regarde l'austérité
du truc tout était plus sombre c'est ça
c'était son cost il travaillait avec la
chemise travailleurs mais parfois il y
avait quand même une forme de clarté
dans le fond et surtout regardera elle
n'y a pas une goutte de rouge du
changement du changement avec vous
emmanuel bon alors la vraie volonté de
faire encore un extérieur avec les gens
et c'est pour le coup je pense que c'est
une vraie photo à chasser d'accord tu
vois là il ya un vrai truc de john
visage penché te regarde bien dans les
yeux de petits sourires mais pas de je
rigole un truc de sérénité oui un peu
plus bienveillants ça va bien se passer
si tu regarde je n'attaquais pas ça va
mal c'est tout le code a voulu être
envoyés de casser l'image politique et
en fait ça s'accorde très bien avec le
vous tu vois macron avec vous c'est que
de l'intimité en fait à tous les codes
de l'intimité sur la photo l'intimité de
la proximité avec les gens qui sont ici
c'est bon là c'était ça ou nous tous
mais parce que j'ai que ce soit nous
tous nous avec vous de toute manière
pour moi c'est le avec vous le nous tous
les gens dernière très proche beaucoup
de personnes ce petit regard des deux
penchés avec la veste ça lui a permis de
ne pas avoir de veste de costume parce
que leader son manteau parce qu'il est
dehors tatouer le mot clé c'est intimité
en fait avec toi beaucoup plus photos
naturelles bah oui tout ce qu'on a vu de
là pour le coup il n'y a pas de hasard
tu vois il prend pas beaucoup de place
de base parce que c'est pour le coup le
npa qui prend le dit jamais je sur une
interview nous il dit nous pensons que
nous croyons que mêmes regards 10 mai
entre nîmes et derrière l'urgence
anticapitaliste tu vois c'est vraiment
porteur de tout le reste quoi tu vois
c'est assez clair et même là on regarde
on revoit le logo du npa ici et puis
après avec les couleurs révolutionnaire
évidemment qui a par contre bien sûr le
ski le joueur décontracté bas plutôt le
si l'ouvrier en vrai avec le vert' la
casquette du coup ils regardent pas les
gens ne regardent pas les gens veulent
en fait il ya un espèce de jeu je fuis
ma médiatisation je peux je pense plus
que curly de la comparer avec alana fils
de nathalie arthaud pascal nathalie
arthaud qui représenterait lui tour
ouvrière ou là on va retrouver le rouge
la banderole on est presque en mode
manif août à même le tse le la typo ça
c'est un vrai code de chez lutte
ouvrière 2 le 30 le temps où tu vas le
tampon comme philippe poutou n'y a pas
de costume de cravates de machin c'est
de la vraie vie rien d'étonnant là je
trouve qu'il joue dans l'est dans les
codes de leur catégorie l'un comme
l'autre quoi tu vois pas lui plus
souriant mal alors que la sq a envoyé
c'est quand même la notion de combat
nous aures 2
honneur aux dames marine le pen alors la
tient visage très centré et le 13e temps
aussi au regard de femme d'état
je me suis à pas d'un slogan d'extrême
droite voulait pas marqué la france la
france qui comme elle choisir la france
dit non entre guillemets visant à lier
tout ça mais par contre apple et at&t
avait pas d'ambiguïté c'est choisir la
france là et d'ailleurs at a vu emmanuel
macron c'était ensemble la france tout
était dans le truck la france la foule
centré sur la personnalité et ça marche
avec le titre femme d'état c'est clc
limite la fiche c'est la photo qui
pourrait mettre après dans les mairies
quoi oui pour moi ouais ça envoie le
signal de ses bonds s'est pressée elle
c'est là et tu vois qu'il ya le logo
cherche le locaux n'y a pas à simplement
nationale même ça renvoie pas vain
le site du rassemblement national non
sedar le site de campagne il ya tout le
monde a cherché je trouve à se
dépouiller de l'image
parfois peut-être un peu lourdes ou
vieillissantes du parti socialiste ou
parti communiste français ou
rassemblement national une espèce de
truc donnant on incarne nos projets nous
même et le parti est secondaire enfin je
trouve que ça envoie ça très très
austère pour aller en contraste avec le
tice et le pays de visages rayonnants
souriant les yeux humides qui sont mis
en valeur beaucoup de clarté ici presse
est d'alger le symbole que dans dans le
sombre est clair un petit coup un peu
comme suit mme akoué un truc un peu de
bienveillance sûr mais c'est vrai que
c'est marrant que les deux qu'ils soient
au second tour il est tendu où un commun
dans l'art affiche moi ça se ressemble
un peu à ils ont beaucoup de points
communs avec une maison comme est pareil
l'ambiance plutôt sombre quand même au
global avec deux visages très lumineux
la même expression de visage si tu
regardes les bouches le regard c'est
pareil il et il n'est pas terme mais il
n'est pas en plein sourire exprès non
plus les yeux de t'inquiète filasses et
tatata gros visage centre et est
et là c'est tout sur elle et là c'est
toute l'intimité sur vos voitures c'est
dans un jeu vidéo tu choisis avec deux
personnages fumer tue ou eric zemmour a
alors voir qu'est-ce qu'on prend caisse
comprend caisse comprends pas je prends
des codes
un peu partie des aides de l'extérieur
avec le flou ça encore une fois c'est
que de les codes des partis classiques
on va dire de la droite classique ou de
la gauche classique ça par contre tu
vois lui impossible n'est pas français
c'est très anciennement front national
où elle le pen père pour le coup je
trouve qu'ils récupèrent en fait tous
les codes que le rn a essayé de se
dépouiller un petit peu là sept
dernières années du coup des arts au
prix cash en disant ça c'est bien moi tu
vois pas ce qu'il ya de ça tu vois là un
possible départ français français en
énorme au niveau des couleurs à la
couleur c'est quelque chose d'aussi
décès de ces apaisant aussi bien beau
mais c'est maintenant l'apaisement
forcément eric zemmour là c'est quand
même quelque chose de ces appels ont
même sur son visage sa sé nout c'est un
acte fort derrière ça se veut léger
sourire en bessin je ne suis pas sûr que
sur cette campagne d'ailleurs y a des il
ya une espèce de truc de personnes à sa
tête de combattants tu vois un regard
des mêmes poutou mais mélenchon mais on
sait pas si le sourire qui parmi nous il
est là moi je me souviens d'anciennes
affiches sur les anciennes campagnes où
c'était toi genre là impossible n'est
pas français serait plus plus dur que ce
à quoi tu vois là c'est impossible n'est
pas français
mais ça va j'ai pas grand chose à dire
vrai ils ont ils ont fait très standard
là aussi deux onces entre le visage on
met juste le message ici en gros
comprend anti flou artistique derrière
n'ont pas pas grand chose à dire
les affiches trop longtemps bon bah
écoutez c'est pas fait exprès loïc a
saigné du nez il a il a vu les douze
affiches des candidats durant un peu
trop longtemps on a essayé d'en dire un
maximum quand il y avait des choses à
dire encore une fois c'était une analyse
relativement subjectif peut-être vous
avez vu autre chose que nous qui serait
intéressant a commenté donc dites le
dans les commentaires je serais assez
intéressé j'ai pas voulu faire ça avant
le premier tour pour pas que ça fasse
des brouhahas bon maintenant que les dés
sont jetés et qu'on sait quels sont les
deux candidats qui a au deuxième tour on
pouvait se permettre de se faire cette
petite analyse rétrospective des
affiches de tout le monde pensez aussi à
vous abonner à la chaîne ici c'est pas
déjà le cas parce qu'on est bientôt
proche des 2 millions en route pour les
deux millions d'abonnés en tout cas
prévu quelque chose pour ça évidemment
n'hésitez pas à activer la cloche pour
voir toutes les vidéos passent et les
vidéos comme celle ci qui sont pas
prévues bref c'est tout ce que tu as à
dire loïc on va aller s'occuper de rick
rendez vous lundi à 18 et à très bientôt
ciao